les hommes qui travaillent pour moi
doivent être capables de violence
pourquoi il faut qu'on mette le feu déjà
s'appelle envoyer un message
arnott vous fait confiance et la
confiance a beaucoup de valeur
aujourd'hui
qu'elle n'est pas seulement ton employé
c'est aussi ton ami
je veux vraiment le respect qui vient
avec ce travail c'est pas du respect
c'est de la peur désolé de te déranger
le qu est ce que tu parles je suis la
distraction
allons tuer ce témoin on s'en occupe
nous a repérés je vais l'intercepter
on n'arrête pas le progrès
patron il ya peut-être de témoin
débarrassons nous de la fille
vous voulez quoi
on va recruter mort je te remets ma
démission
pourchassés c'est quoi ton plan dans ce
cas là
c'est toujours un tueur à gages et moi
je suis la police ouais j'ai les armes
beaucoup d'armes
je vais ramener la policière à monsieur
seulement
hockey
il faut se débarrasser des deux peut
importe que ça coûte je m'en moquais
patron
[Musique]
j'ai appris une vérité est réfutable
guette les criminels sont toujours leur
pire ennemi regarde moi
[Musique]